Okay.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Elfbeza Toru.
Ich bin hier als Assistent-Assistent hier in der Station tätig
und würde gerne das Aufnahmengespräch mit Ihnen durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Karin Meyerhoff.
Äh, bitte langsam Buchstabilden.
Ja, der Vorname K-A-R-I-N.
Mhm.
Und der Familie-Name M-E-Y-E-R-H-O-F.
O-Double-F.
Mhm, Meyerhoff.
Meyerhoff.
Okay.
Und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 8.03.87 geboren.
Äh, 87.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
8,60 m.
Und wie wie wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Ja, ich wiege so ungefähr 75 kg.
75 kg.
Und wer ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Äh, Dr. Hoffmann.
Hoffmann mit D-F-B-F.
Und D-F-B-F.
Am Ende.
Okay, äh, und was fühlt Sie denn zu uns?
Ja, also mir ist es irgendwie gerade ganz komisch gegangen.
Ähm, mein Mann hat mich hierher gebracht.
Und irgendwie, das ist jetzt schon drei Stunden her,
da hab ich mit einmal so ganz komisch so Zuckungen gehabt
in den Armen und in den Beinen.
Ich hab das überhaupt noch nie gehabt.
Und...
Mhm.
Das war mir so ein bisschen unheimlich.
Und dann hab ich überlegt, so ungefähr eine halbe Stunde davor,
hatte ich so komische Sehstürungen,
da hab ich nur gedacht, ich hab vielleicht zu doll in die Sonne geguckt.
Aber da hab ich so Lichtblitze gesehen.
Und hatte auch ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen.
Und dann dachte ich schon, irgendwas ist nicht in Ordnung.
Und dann fing das komische mit Zuckungen halt an hinterher.
Mhm.
Okay.
Äh, und das ist das erste Mal, sagen Sie.
Ich hab so was noch nie erlebt.
Deswegen bin ich hierhergekommen, wenn mir das ein bisschen unheimlich war.
Und danach, wissen Sie, danach hab ich mich so gefühlt,
als ob ich irgendwie den Garten umgegraben hab.
Ich war total schlapp und müde.
Mhm.
Und mir war total schlecht, ja.
Und ich war aber auch eigentlich so ein bisschen...
Ja, so, so dass ich nicht zur Ruhe kommen konnte.
Okay.
Und wie fühlen Sie Todzeit?
Ja, jetzt geht es mir langsam eigentlich besser.
So ein bisschen schlapp bin ich noch, ja.
Und also, Essen würde ich jetzt, glaube ich, auch nichts wollen.
Mir ist so ein bisschen schlecht noch, ja, so ein bisschen Übelkeit.
Okay.
Übelkeit auch.
Und müssen Sie, mussten Sie sich auch übergeben, auch?
Nee, das ist zum Glück nicht, ne?
Mhm.
Und Sie haben ja gesagt Kopfschmerzen, Sie haben.
Und wo haben Sie genau Schmerzen haben,
hinter dem Kopf oder im umgangsenden Kopf?
Also, ich meine, das war so praktisch im Stirnbereich,
nach hinten ziehend, aber auf beiden Seiten.
Beiden Seiten?
Mhm.
Und haben Sie sich das bewusst sein verloren?
Nee, ganz sicher nicht.
Nee, da bin ich mir ganz sicher, dass ich das alles mitbekomme.
Aber mit einmal waren diese komischen Zuckerungen da,
und das konnte ich irgendwie nicht beeinflussen.
Okay.
Und...
Vor dem Erreignis haben Sie...
aufhälliges gegessen oder gemacht?
Ja, also, das ist schon länger her.
Also gestern Abend hatten wir bei der Arbeit eine Party,
wo wir relativ viel Alkohol getrunken haben.
Aber ich trink ja schon gelegentlich mal ein bisschen was.
Aber das wäre das Einzige, was ich mir so vorstellen könnte.
Okay. Und haben Sie sich den Kopf gestoßen, heute oder gestern?
Nee, also, da ist auch keine Beule oder so was.
Nee, da ist nichts.
Mhm.
Okay. Und hatten Sie Fieber?
Oh, habe ich natürlich nicht gemessen.
Wüsste ich ja nicht.
Aber also, Fieber ich habe mich eigentlich nicht gefühlt zu keinem Zeitpunkt.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder was sein lassen?
Also, normalerweise habe ich schon ein bisschen Darmprobleme, ja.
Also, ich habe, das sagt man so, dass ich ein bisschen Reizdarm hab.
Und wenn ich dann also so sehr viel durchfalle,
da muss ich auch mal so Immodium nehmen.
Aber normalerweise habe ich eigentlich,
also, ja, sonst, damit komme ich eigentlich gut.
Aber das war jetzt nicht irgendwie besonders diese Tage.
Ähm, okay.
Äh, und ...
Und ...
Äh, haben Sie Taubheitsgefühle, Kribbeln oder Lemungen aufgefallen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nee, also, wie gesagt, ich konnte das nur nicht steuern,
so dieses, komische Bewegung, aber Taubheit oder so,
hatte ich eigentlich nicht, nee.
Ähm, und ...
Haben Sie Schlafstörung?
Ja, also, ich schlafe wirklich nicht besonders gut, das stimmt.
Mhm.
Und, ähm, wieso das in Durchschlafstörung oder Einschlafstörung
leiten Sie an?
Ich leide eigentlich mehr so an ...
Also, Einschlafstörung.
Ich bin oft so ein bisschen nervös, ja.
Und, ähm ...
Dann kann ich nicht einschlafen.
Und wenn ich dann erst mal schlafe, ist gut.
Aber wenn ich durch irgendwas aufgeweckt werde,
also früher, wenn mit dem Kind irgendwas war oder so,
dass das Nacht geweint hat,
dann konnte ich auch wieder nicht mehr einschlafen.
Einschlafen, okay.
Und, ähm, Sie haben, ja gesagt,
Sie haben eine Leisternsyndrom
und Fernsehtedurchfälle, ähm, leiden Sie.
Ja.
Wie viele, ähm, äh,
wie viele am Tag gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Also, wenn alles gut geht einmal,
aber an den Tagen, wo es halt mal schlecht ist,
dann muss ich auch schon drei, vier Mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Mhm.
Äh, und, ähm, haben Sie an einer Vorallkrankung,
den ich wissen sollte?
Ja, eigentlich das Einzige, was so ...
jetzt bekannt ist, ist diese Reizdarmgeschichte.
Das andere ist alles so Kleinkram, ja.
Also, ich hab so ein bisschen eine Hautveränderung hinterm Ohr.
Da muss ich eben so eine spezielle Salbe anwenden.
Mein Knie tut mir hin und wieder weh.
Und, ähm, dann hab ich, also,
oftmals so, bin ich so heiser und kann nicht gut sprechen.
Da hat mir mein, mein,
Hals-Nasen-Ohrenarzt mal gesagt,
ich hab Stimmbandknötchen.
Und da kann ich, also manchmal nur so eingeschränkt sprechen,
dann bin ich so chronisch heiser.
Und wenn das besonders unangenehm ist,
dann muss ich halt so ein bisschen Luststabletten nehmen,
damit ich besser sprechen kann.
Okay. Und wegen der Knieweh, ähm,
waren Sie bei einem Orthopäten?
Ja, bisher noch nicht.
Also, wenn ich da was hab, dann nehm ich ein bisschen
so Schmerzgel und reib mir das Knie ein.
Aber, also, was da genau mit ist,
hab ich jetzt noch nicht gemacht, nachgefragt.
Okay. Und, ähm, Sie nehmen wegen der Reizdäum-Imodium,
sagten, haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, aber nur, wenn es gerade schlimm ist,
nicht regelmäßig natürlich.
Okay. Und, ähm, für, ähm,
harte Veränderung hinter dem Ohr,
ähm, was benutzt du denn Sie?
Ja, das ist so eine Salbe, die heißt Lugal.
Lugal? Salbe.
Mhm.
Und nehmen, ähm, benutzt du denn Sie die regelmäßig?
Nein, nur, wenn ich merke, dass das gerade wieder akut ist,
dass das juckt und, und dass das schuppt oder so.
Und dann verwend ich diese Creme an.
Okay. Und wegen der Stimmbandknötchen,
ähm, ähm, nehmen Sie Lusch-Tabletten und, ähm,
wissen Sie die Tablettennamen?
Ja, also, der, der, der Arzt hat mir mal empfohlen,
Leo-Angine.
Mhm.
Und, ähm, ich mag die nur nicht so besonders,
weil die so, so sehr die Zunge betäuben, ne?
Aber, also, die nehme ich halt dann, wenn ich sehr heiser bin, ne?
Ja, ne? Okay.
Und, ähm, nehmen Sie andere Medikamente regelmäßig
oder bei Bedarf ein?
Ne, sonst eigentlich, ich hab bisher ja nie,
nie viel aufregende Sachen gehabt, ne?
Okay. Und, ähm, wurde Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nein.
Operiert, so weit ich mich erinner kann,
weil hab ich jemals eine Operation, nein.
Nein, ich bin nie operiert worden.
Okay.
Äh, und, haben Sie Allergien oder, äh,
Liebesmittelunfallträglichkeiten?
Ja, da muss ich tatsächlich aufpassen.
Also, äh, was ich nicht essen darf,
ist also, Fisch und, ähm, Muscheln und Krabben
und all solche Sachen.
Das kann ich alles nicht vertragen.
Äh, und, ähm, als Allergie ist mir also,
ja, eine lästige Geschichte,
so diese Hausstaubmilbenallergie.
Dass ich dann, also, ließen muss
und dass die Augen ganz rot sind und so.
Ich muss also immer gucken,
dass ich gut, äh, sauber mache
und, äh, dass ich, äh,
was, was ich Staub, Arme, Betten hab und so.
Okay. Und wie aussetzt sich das Mädelsfrüchte Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, also, da wird, da wird mir schlecht
und ich bekomme auch so ein bisschen Luftnot.
Also, das hat man einmal, hab ich das erlebt
und seither hat man mir gesagt,
so lassen sie das lieber weckel und, und, ne?
Okay, verstehe.
Äh, und, äh, rauchen Sie, äh, Frau Meuerhof?
Ja, ich rauch nicht viel, aber ich rauch schon, ja,
in Haldespäckchen am Tag rauch ich.
Halbespäckchen? Seid's wann?
Ach, würde man sagen, seit ich 18 bin eigentlich,
hab ich damit angefangen, ja.
Denn als ich schwanger war, hab ich das mal für ein paar Monate
ausgesetzt, aber ja, danach hab ich auch schon wieder angefangen,
ja, also, aber nie so richtig viel.
Und Sie haben ja gesagt, Sie gelegentlich Alkoholkonsum,
ist das richtig?
Ja, also, das jetzt gestern, das war wirklich ein bisschen sehr viel.
Das passiert mir eigentlich nicht so oft, aber normalerweise,
ja, dass man so am Wochenende mal was trinkt
oder wenn es was zu feiern gibt, ja, aber eben so wie jetzt
gestern, da war ein bisschen viel, ja.
Durchschnittlich, eines Mal pro Woche.
Ein bis zwei Mal pro Woche, ja.
Und das ist, das ist eine Rettunerfrage.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Ja.
Ja, das ist schon lange her, da hab ich mal so ein bisschen
Cannabis mal konsumiert.
Aber war schon lange her.
Das ist für eine Mal?
Ja, also schon ein bisschen mehr als einmal,
ja, aber ja, so das war nie sehr intensiv.
Okay. Und sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Malen Sie gegen Covid oder so?
Ja, in Covid bin ich dreimal geimpft und
als Kind habe ich natürlich diese ganzen Impfungen bekommen
und, ja, sonst,
ja, Grippe-Impfungen habe ich dieses Jahr auch gemacht, ja.
Okay. Und waren Sie erst im Ausland?
Im Ausland bin ich nicht gewesen.
Nee, gar nicht.
Okay.
Und ihr werdet Ihre Periode aufnehmen.
Wahnsinn, Frau Dr. Tor, ich kann Sie gerade ganz schlecht verstehen.
Können Sie einmal gucken, Ihre Internetverbindung?
Ja.
Wir haben so Mikrostörungen.
Probieren Sie nochmal, ob ich es jetzt besser verstehen kann?
Ja, okay.
Ich versuche es mal.
Ja, jetzt ist es gut wieder.
Ist gut, ja.
Okay.
Und wie sieht Ihre Periode aus?
Bekommen Sie die noch?
Ja, ich bin erst 38.
Okay.
Regelmäßig.
Und besuchen Sie Ihre Voranarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, also wenn ich es nicht vergesse, ja,
aber eigentlich versuche ich einmal im Jahr hinzugehen, ja.
Okay, das ist schon mal gut.
Und in der Familienanahmenese
leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben beide noch, ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Und
haben Sie eine Vorerkrankung?
Meine Eltern, ob die Vorerkrankungen haben.
Also meine Mutter quält sich im Augenblick sehr.
Die hatte sich das Handgelenke
gebrochen und die hat danach
ein, das nennt sich Morbus Sudek,
die ist also sehr schmerzgeplagt
und die ist wirklich
deutlich eingeschränkt dadurch und quält sich sehr.
Und ich hoffe, dass es ihr bald besser geht.
Aber sonst wüsste ich nicht, dass die irgendwie so
andere Krankheiten hat.
Und welches Handgelenke?
Das ist Linke zum Glück.
Linke.
Aber es ist eben furchtbar schmerzhaft, ne?
Und wurde das operativ behandelt?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay. Und Ihr Vater
ist gesund?
Also so viel. Ich weiß, ich wüsste nicht, dass der irgendwas hat.
Okay. Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder und eine Schwester,
aber ich glaube, die sind auch fit.
Also die sind noch jünger als ich.
Ich glaube, die sind fit.
Ja.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Mein Mann ist ja mitgekommen, hat mich ja hergebracht.
Ja, okay. Und Sie haben Kinder?
Ein Kind habe ich.
Ein Kind und
ist eher kindgesund?
Mein Kind? Ja, ja, das ist fit und
zum Glück geht es wunder.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, also wir haben so einen Kopierlagen.
Wir sind also selbstständig.
Und da bin ich halt im
Laden ziemlich viel.
Okay. Das heißt, Sie haben vermehrt Stress in der Arbeit?
Ja, schon klar, weil man immer natürlich darauf angewiesen ist,
dass alles funktioniert und
dass genug Kunden kommen, dass die Werbung läuft.
Ja, das ist schon manchmal ein bisschen Stress.
Ja. Okay.
Und Frau Meier-Foth, ich bin fertig mit dem Fragen und
haben Sie noch etwas fragen?
Ob ich doch Fragen habe?
Also
für mich ist es eigentlich nur die Frage, wie kommt das, dass das diese komische Sache war?
Und das war so ein bisschen gespenstisch und mir macht das ein bisschen Angst.
Ich möchte halt jetzt schon wissen, was kann man dagegen tun oder wie kann man das abklären?
Ja, erst mal möchte ich mir
die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen.
Zu diesem Diagnose zu verschiedenen Bestätigen.
Möchte ich erst mal die körperliche Untersuchung und Blut abnehmen
und ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und ihr halt möchte ich gerne mit meinem Oberarzt
besprechen und gehe zurück zu ihr und sage ihnen, was
was ist mit ihnen zu tun.
Und
werden wir danach therapeutisch
eingehen.
Ah ja, wenn wir wissen, was es ist, kann man auch sagen, was man dagegen tun kann, so zu sagen.
Ja. Ja. Okay.
Gut, ja. Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank. 80 Minuten ist gut.
Erste Animes.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Ja, Sie haben
zukünftige Probleme.
Sie leiden unter zukünftigen Probleme.
Haben Sie beide seitlich oder nur einseitlich?
Beide Arme und beide Beine.
Beide Arme und beide Arme.
Okay.
Zwei andere Fragen.
Erinnern Sie sich daran gut, was passiert ist oder haben Sie eine Vergesslichkeit Probleme?
Nee, Vergesslichkeit nicht.
Also ich kann mich schon erinnern an diese Situation.
Aber ich fühle mich halt so erschöpft und so müde hinterher.
Okay. Vielen Dank.
Ich habe zwei Fragen.
Ja, bitte.
Frau Mayhoff, haben Sie auf das Zunge gebissen,
während des Anfans?
Nein, meine Zunge habe ich mir nicht.
Nein, da habe ich nicht drauf gebissen.
Okay. Und haben Sie
haben Sie unwihlkürliche Wasser gelassen,
während des Anfans?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also Sie meinen, ob ich mich eingenäßt habe.
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht. Nein.
Okay, danke.
Darf ich noch andere Fragen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja, denn.
Okay, verstehe.
Eine andere Kollegin hat gefragt,
Kopfschmerzen und Beschreibung.
Und, äh, hat die Kollegin aber gefragt.
Ja, hat gefragt, wo die Kopfschmerzen waren.
Ne, und ob die Beidseite waren.
Beschreibung keine.
Ach so, der Qualitätsschmerzqualität.
Und Stärke nicht gefragt.
Stimmt, ja.
Ja, also.
Ja, was können wir sagen?
Ähm, die Schmerzen waren, waren jetzt nicht so graviert.
Leicht.
Vielleicht so auf der Skala 4 bis 5.
Und ähm,
eher
Dächende Schmerzen, würde ich sagen.
Ähm, haben Sie diese Fall vorher stimuliert oder erst mal?
Ich, ich, ich erinnere mich nicht diese Fall.
Noch mal, bitte.
Haben Sie diese Fall vorher Stimulation gemacht oder erst mal?
Diese Simulation, die habe ich sogar mit Ihnen gemacht.
Ja.
Am 17.08.23.
Sie erinnern die App, nicht sie waren.
Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Das ist ungewöhnlich.
Ja.
Sie erinnern sich eigentlich immer an alle.
Natürlich hieß die Frau anders damals, aber ähm.
23.
Mhm.
Und zuletzt habe ich die im Februar 24 gemacht.
Mit Herrn Demirell.
Demirell.
Also, es geht nichts verloren, Dr.
Günness.
Ja.
Könnte wir erst als Kirche beginnen?
Ja, Sie sind zu weit, Frau Donsert-Hoffel.
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Mhm.
Guten Tag Frau Oberersten.
Wir haben eine neue Patientin und ihr Fall möchte ich gerne mit Ihnen besprechen.
Darf ich kurz die Patientin vorstellen?
Aber ja, wie haben Sie den gesehen?
Okay, ähm, die Patientin heißt Karin Meierhoff.
Und ist 30 Jahre alt.
Und ähm, die Patientin ist 30 Jahre alt.
Äh, und sie hat sich ähm, äh, sie hat sich äh, bei uns wegen drei Stunden, äh, drei Stunden, ähm, bestehende Kopfschmerzen
und ähm, in beiden Exzellenmitäten aufgetretener Myoklinien vorgestellt.
Und ähm, vor dem Myoklinien waren äh, die Patientin Lichtbritze äh, ähm, aufgefallen.
Äh, und äh, die Patientin, perner gibt es, äh, perner gibt sie an, dass die Kopfschmerzen äh, stechende und die beidseitige äh,
sei, äh, und nach dem ähm, äh Anfall ähm, fühle sie schlepp und äh, fühle sie äh erschöppt.
Äh, und äh, das Bewusstsein, äh, noch nie ähm, das Bewusstsein habe sie äh, noch nicht äh, verloren.
Haben sie, haben sie nicht verloren, okay.
Und äh, Schmerzintensität äh, wurde mit äh, vier bis fünf ähm, auf eine Schmerzskala bewertet.
Was die Tefalgin angeht?
Äh, ja äh, Zephalgin.
Mhm.
Zephalgin.
Äh, und ähm, darüber hinaus ähm, ähm, äh, sei äh, bei äh, die Patientin äh, folgende Burg,
Megal Symptome, aufgefallen, äh, Übelkeit, äh, und äh, Übelkeit, äh, und ähm, die
vegetative Anamnese äh, sind äh, unaufwähig, äh bis auf äh, äh, Diarröen, äh, wegen
der Reizdam-Syndrom, äh, und äh, die Patientin habe äh, Hiserkeit, äh, wegen der
äh, Stimmbandknotchen, äh, und äh, sie fühle sich in letzter Zeit äh, nervös.
Äh, und äh, sie äh, leide an ähm, Insomnia.
Mhm.
Äh, Anvorerkrankungen, leide sie äh, äh, Kolonirritable, äh, und äh, Post-
Noch einmal etwas bitte.
Ein?
Äh, Kolonirritable, Reizdam.
Ah, die Reizdam ist fast da, ja.
Und äh, Post-Aurikulare, Exantem.
Mhm.
Äh, und äh, ähm, äh, Vokalkort-Knotchen, äh, an Medikamentin,
nehmens die ähm, Emodium, Barbedarf, äh, Legorzabler Barbedarf,
Neuer-Anzins, Barbedarf.
Mhm.
Äh, und ähm, äh, die, die Patienten wurden noch nie operiert.
Äh, äh, und ähm, äh, sie, äh, sei ähm, äh, allergisch wegen,
gegen Haus-Äh, Staubmilben, und äh, äh, die Allergie
äußert sich mit ähm, Genokonjunktivitis, äh, und ähm, sie allergisch
auch ähm, sie sei allergisch auch äh, Mehlfrüchte, und äh, einmal
äh, habe sie ähm, Luftnot äh, bekommen.
Mhm.
Äh, und äh, sie sei Raucherin, ähm, seit ähm, 18. Lebensjahr, ähm,
äh, halbis äh, Päckchen äh, pro Tag, und äh, sie äh,
konsumiere ähm, ein bis zweimal probere Alkohol, aber
gestern ähm, äh, habe sie äh, vermehrt Alkohol äh, getrunken.
Mhm, äh, ja, okay.
Und äh, äh, mit dem Drucken ähm, äh, sie habe äh, Kontakt ähm,
in ähm, äh, Jugendjahren äh, mit Cannabis.
Aber in äh, in letzter Zeit ähm, habe sie nicht Kontakt.
Mhm.
Und ähm, äh, sie sei äh, vorständig geimpft, äh, und äh,
ähm, die genäkologische Anamnese war unauffällig.
Und in der Familienanamnese fanden sich ähm, äh,
Linke, äh, Linke, handgelegt ähm, äh, Fraktur äh,
Muttern herseits und ähm, der Vater äh, ist, sei gesund.
Äh, die Patientin habe zwei Geschwister äh, sie sind auch gesund.
Ähm, sie, sind verheirat, ähm, sie sei verheiratet und habe
eine gesunde Kinder.
Ein gesundes Kind?
Ein gesundes Kind.
Ähm, sie sei voll, äh, selbst, selbstständig, äh, und habe
eine Kopialaden, äh, und äh, sie leide in letzter Zeit
thermatisch stress bei der Arbeit.
Mhm.
Äh, äh, die ähm, aufgrund der anamnistischen
Angaben gehe ich vor eine ähm, epileptischen Anfall äh, aus.
Äh, dafür äh, sprechen vor allem äh, die äh,
Mio-Klonien und die äh, ähm, Anfall anamnäse ähm, ähm,
ähm, ähm, äh, vor der äh, äh, gestern ähm,
übermäßige Alkoholkonsum äh, süpplicht äh, auch.
Mhm.
Ähm, und differenzial diagnostisch äh, kommen hier ähm,
ähm, Migräne äh, äh, die Aura.
Und äh, ähm, hier ein Tümer ähm, äh, und ähm,
Hippoglycemi äh, äh, in Wetter.
Auch, ja.
Mhm.
Und das vielleicht noch, ja.
Äh, und zum weiteren Ab, Abklärung äh, würde ich
departieren den Körper-Lehrund-Untersuchung ähm,
woauf ach, wie sind sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ähm, mit Fokus, mit Fokus auf neurologische Untersuchung.
Mhm.
Äh, und äh, ich möchte Blut abnehmen, äh, kleines Blutbild ähm,
und ähm, Gidecos äh, und ähm, äh, Hb äh, A1c, äh,
äh, Werze.
Okay, um äh, äh, Bulge-Kimi auszuschließen, ja.
Mhm.
Äh, ich würde ein EKG veranlassen, ähm, äh,
Ein EKG?
EKG?
Mhm.
Äh, und ähm, bei Bedarf ähm, ähm, veranlasse ich ein
MRT, äh, zum organischen ähm, Gähchen ähm,
Krankheiten auszuschließen.
Ja, äh, um, um da ein ähm, was Organisches auszuschließen, ja,
genau.
Okay.
Und ähm, äh, was würden sie für die, für die ähm, Epilepsidiagnostik
unter unschätten, also, wie würde Ihre neurologische Untersuchung
um Einzelnen aussehen?
Ähm, neurologischen Untersuchung, ähm,
nach dem epileptischen Fall, ähm, ähm, ähm,
würde das alles normal bei der Patientin?
Mhm.
Und veranlasse ich ein EKG, ähm, um äh, eine Äh,
Epilepsi äh, zu diagnostisieren.
Mhm.
Ja, aber das ist ja genau das Problem, ne,
dass man im, im anfallsfreien Zustand sieht man ja
die Ärzte, die man in der Ärzte veranlasst.
Ja.
Mhm.
Na gut, ja, aber man würde jetzt sicherlich so zur Kontrolle
in EEG machen.
Und so ich.
Ja, aber ja, wie würde noch mal so Ihre neurologische
Untersuchung, worauf würden Sie speziell jetzt äh,
achten, was würden Sie mit Händen, Augen, Ohren
machen?
Ähm, ich überprüfe die Kranialnerven.
Mhm.
Und die, ähm, Muskelkraft, äh, und den, ja,
Reflexe, ähm, Muskeleigenreflexe.
Überprüfe ich.
Ja.
Mhm.
Und das Gleichgewicht auch.
Okay, ja.
Mhm.
Ja, okay, gut, ja.
Gut, ähm, wenn sich das jetzt bestätigt,
was würden wir denn dann machen?
Mit Ihr?
Ähm, ja, ähm, bei der Patientin, ähm, würde ich
ein, äh, Antipläptika anfangen.
Mhm.
Ähm, und ähm, auch sogar zum ersten Mal.
Nein, ähm, würde das bestätigt, ähm.
Nur wenn es bestätigt, ja, aber wie wird es bestätigt,
eigentlich nur?
Ähm, ich würde das bestätigt, ähm,
nach dem, äh, zwei, äh, Anfall innerhalb des...
Ja, eben, das ist das Problem, genau.
Wir können eigentlich nur alles andere ausschließen.
Ja.
Und, ähm, dann, äh, dann können wir sagen, ja,
vermutlich war es ein epileptischer Anfall.
Und, ähm, wie würden wir dann erst mal weiter vorgehen?
Ja, wir haben das, ähm,
das, ähm,
wie würden wir dann erst mal weiter vorgehen?
Ja, ähm, innerhalb der, ähm, sechs Monaten,
ähm, falls eine epileptische Anfall, ähm, vorhanden, ähm,
können wir...
Ich, ich, ich, Frau, Frau Gerhard, ähm, diese Patientin,
eine epileptische Fall, oder?
Bitte?
Diese Fall, eine epileptische Fall.
Ja.
Welche Symptome gehabt, ähm, keine ähm, äh,
Beusse, Beine...
Zukunft in Armen und, Armen und Beinen
und diese Lichtplätze in der, im, im Vorfeld.
Eine halbe Stunde vorher, ne?
Äh, äh, auch ne ähm,
eine Beusse, ein Verloren, ähm,
epileptische erst mal ähm,
sehr selten aufgetreten sind.
Okay, ich hab, äh, zu Bewusstsein von euch hab ich,
hab ich, hier fall, hier fall, äh,
meistens multibelsikleros, ähm, äh, äh, äh,
denken wir multibelsikleros, ein, diese Fall, ich
denke, sagen wir nochmal, denken wir...
Multibelsiklerose, diese
multibelsiklerose.
Ach, multibelsiklerose, okay.
Ja, ja.
Also, sie, es ist als, als Fall für mich
aufgeführt mit Epilepsie.
Ja, aber keine ähm,
keine Beussein, ähm,
Herr Lorenz.
Ja, oder vielleicht so'n, so'n, ja.
Fokal, ähm, Epilepsie,
kann sein, aber dieses Fall, Symptome,
ähm, schipplicht, ähm, multibelsiklerose.
Okay.
Also, ich kann nur das immer sagen, was ich aus,
aus den Fallbeschreibungen habe, sorry.
Ja.
Und ähm, ähm, äh, also ich hab hier keinen
Hinweis auf, ähm, auch für Wurstseinsverlust,
dass sie, dass sie, äh,
nicht dabei war, sozusagen.
Ähm, ähm,
und ich meine eigentlich, ähm, wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere,
dass auch Epileptiker selber sagen, äh, sie
sie sind eigentlich die ganze Zeit wach,
sie kriegen alles mit.
Ja.
Ne? Also insofern, ja,
muss ich tatsächlich jetzt nochmal nachgucken.
Also, gut, äh, aber äh,
die entscheidende Geschichte ist jetzt
tatsächlich, dass man im Augenblick,
im Nachhinein, praktisch nichts feststellen kann,
man kann nicht sagen,
ja, zum Beispiel, diese Patient,
Symptome, Zerstörungs, äh,
Taupaus gefüllt, muskul-schwehe,
Schwindel, äh,
hat sie ja nicht gesagt.
Schwerke Musikkeit, äh,
Emotion,
die Nachgümbanfall.
Ja, aber es ist,
äh,
Frauen, diese Fall,
erst malik, äh,
wir denken, eine Ferdag,
wir machen uns Mutibisikleros.
Okay.
Ich kann mit Ihnen nicht über medizinische Fachsachen diskutieren.
Das kann ich nicht, weil ich keine Medizinerin bin.
Das ist ja nicht, ja,
Sie haben nicht, ja, Sie haben nicht.
Also, ich kann immer nur die Fälle so
präsentieren, wie ich sie vorgelegt bekomme.
Ja, so.
Und jetzt müssen wir eben gucken,
dass ich mit der Frau Dr. Togo zum Schluss komme.
Äh, die entscheidende Sache ist tatsächlich,
dass ich mit dem,
der ich mit dem,
die entscheidenden Sache ist tatsächlich,
wir können nicht, äh,
wir können nicht sicher sagen,
das war ein epäleplischer Anfall.
Wir können nur die anderen Sachen ausschließen.
Ja, wir können,
wir können äh,
die Moderäne, ja,
mehr oder weniger ausschließen,
wir können die integer-glücklich-memorie
ausschließen,
wir können den Thoma ausschiessen,
wir können eine äh,
ausschließen über das MRT.
Ja.
Und dann müssen wir davon ausgehen oder können wir davon ausgebildlicherweise, dass es eben
so ein epileptischer Anfall war.
Und da würde man eben die ersten sechs Monate beobachten unter aber bestimmten Konditionen.
Haben Sie eine Vorstellung, worauf muss die Patientin achten in diesen sechs Monaten?
Wie bitte?
Ja, worauf muss soll die Patientin in den nächsten sechs Monaten achten?
Möglichst Stress zum vermeiden.
Einmal ja und?
Was ist noch?
Und regelmäßig schlafen, genugende Schlafen.
Ja und Noxen?
Und Noxen vermeiden ja.
Ja, das ist das.
Das sind eigentlich die Punkte.
Und mehr kann man eigentlich im Augenblick nicht tun.
Genau.
Ja.
Dann können wir jetzt, also ab von den medizinischen Fragtwürdigkeiten, sorry dafür, können
wir aber noch über die sprachlichen Sachen sprechen.
Die Anamnese war super.
Die Anamnese war richtig, richtig gut.
Ein bisschen schwierig wurde es mit ihrem Vortrag, mit ihrer Fallschilder rum.
Da bin ich nicht so ganz einfach standen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass sie da auch, wo sie vorher total sicher waren in der Formulierung,
hatten sie auch ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, die Sätze zu konstruieren.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass sie praktisch die Geschichte, wie das passiert ist, nicht
ganz korrekt beschrieben haben.
Sie hat ja nicht seit drei Stunden, also seit drei Stunden bestehende Zukunft in den Armen
und Beinen, sondern vor drei Stunden war das ein kurzes Ereignis.
Ja, das.
Und die kurze Schmerzen und diese Fotopsie, diese Lichtblitte hatte sie eine halbe Stunde davor.
Ja, wir müssen also das in die richtige zeitliche Reihenfolge bringen, damit es auch wieder gibt,
dass die Patientin geschildert hat.
Ja, das habe ich korrekt verstanden, aber mit den Formulierungen habe ich Probleme
und ja, ich weiß, dass sie eh nicht korrekt…
Ja, also das war einfach nicht richtig beschrieben und das ist aber tatsächlich eine Schwierigkeit,
gerade so diese zeitliche Abfolge, da die richtigen Begriffe zu nehmen, dass man eben sagt,
vor drei Stunden oder seit drei Stunden, ist eben großer Unterschied.
Ja, wenn ich vor fünf Jahren operiert wurde, ja, oder wenn man vor fünf Jahren etwas festgestellt hat,
dann habe ich möglicherweise eine chronische Erkrankung auch seit drei Jahren,
aber ein Punkt ereignet war dann eben vor drei Jahren.
Also das ist diese Geschichte.
Dann, ähm, Augenblick.
Ja, bei der Familienanamnese, da haben sie nur, wie gesagt, die Mutter hat in der Handgelenkfraktur.
Das ist natürlich irgendwie, ja, Unfall kann ja jeder haben, aber Akut ist ja das Problem,
das hat sie ja gesagt, sie hat ein Mobile-Sudeck.
Ja, ja.
Und das ist das, was ihr im Augenblick die Beschwerden macht.
Also Zustand nach Handgelenkfraktur, ne, ja, das kann man haben, aber das ist halt was,
aber es hat natürlich eigentlich jetzt nichts mit ihrer aktuellen Situation zu tun.
Es besagt eigentlich nur, die Mutter ist ansonsten eigentlich gesund, hat aber dieses Problem, ja.
Aber bei der FSB-Prüfung ist diese sehr wichtig.
Ja, eben, also, weil sie das gesagt hat, muss man es erwähnen.
Ja.
Das ist der Punkt.
Wenn die Patientin das jetzt gar nicht gesagt hätte, dann könnten sie das vernachlässigen, ja,
dann wüssten sie es ja auch nicht, aber da, da sie es ausdrücklich gesagt hat,
müssten sie es in der Prüfung halt auch angeben und müssten sogar darauf gefasst sein,
dass die Nachfragen, weil sie tatsächlich auf diese, diese Nebenschienen nutzen,
um nochmal irgendwo was abzufragen.
Ja, das ist diese Geschichte, was mir auch nicht so gut gefallen hat,
dass sie eigentlich die Vorherregangende und auch die nach dem Anfall vorhandenen Nervosität,
haben sie eigentlich oder so Unruhe, das haben sie eigentlich auch gegenüber der Oberärztin
jetzt nicht so richtig erwähnt.
Ja.
Gut, dann ist mir noch eine Sache aufgefallen.
Sie haben praktisch mit der Vegettape in einer Amnese, haben sie diesen,
diesen Reizdarm praktisch so die Verdauungsstörung praktisch,
praktisch schon mit, mit erwähnt.
Ja, das ist immer die Frage, wo gehört das denn?
Es ist ja eine Vorerkrankung oder ist es eben was, was ihr auch in der Vegettape an Annamese Probleme macht?
Also da muss man nur vielleicht nochmal trennen, dass man sagt, das sind, also in der Vegettape an Annamese gibt es
eine Schlafstörung an und eben Nervosität und insbesondere in den letzten Tagen und der als
Vorerkrankung ist bekannt das Reizdarm-Syndrom und Pipa Bo, was dann noch so kam.
Gut, ja, das sind eigentlich die entscheidenden Sachen.
Wichtig war neurologische Untersuchung, dass man halt guckt, genau dieses Reflexe, was sie im Labor nicht mit erwähnt haben.
Elektrolyptik habe ich vergessen.
Elektrolyptik.
Genau.
Die habe ich mir hier noch eingekringelt, genau, dass sie die nicht erwähnt haben und ja, das sind eigentlich genau die entscheidenden Punkte.
Da haben wir aber alles praktisch erwähnt.
Wie gesagt, in der Annamese im Gespräch mit der Patientin waren sie sehr souverän und sehr sicher.
Und nachher in der Ausformulierung der Geschichte gab es ein bisschen Probleme, aber wir haben uns eigentlich zu jedem Augenblick verstanden
und sie haben vielleicht gemerkt, dass ich manchmal so grammatikalisch so ein bisschen korrigiert habe.
Wenn sie eine Formulierung hatten, die nicht so ganz sauber war, dann habe ich ein bisschen das wiederholt und richtig gestellt.
Aber ansonsten würde ich sagen, weil das für das erste Mal richtig super.
Danke.
Gut.